svetlana nunca imaginó ver su casa
destrozada por la artillería esta
peluquera huyó de su hogar en el este de
ucrania con lo que tenía puesto cada día
se pregunta el porqué de esta guerra y
no entiende que sus hermanos rusos
apoyen el ataque a su país
y no entienden lo que está pasando en
dicen que aquí hay nacionalistas
seguidores de bandera dicen que putin es
un líder que lo está haciendo todo bien
19 hizo una propuesta a pesar de que
llevar en guerra desde el 2014 la
ruptura identitaria de los ucranianos
rusoparlantes se siente más profunda en
el donbass que mi pasaporte dice que soy
rusa pero no quiero ese rusa quiero
hablar ucrania no quiero cambiar esa
mentalidad rusa por todo lo que está
pasando
axxion no craft come si quieres que
varió las horas pasan muy lentas en este
centro de libro donde se resguardan los
más vulnerables muchos no tienen acceso
a tratamientos ni revisiones médicas
alexander lleva un mes en este centro de
bolos que este pintor vivía en un
pequeño apartamento propasa cuando la
guerra le arrebató su tranquilidad no
tiene miedo sus dibujos le mantienen
sereno
en 2014 tenía un poco de miedo pero yo
he estado en el ejército y sé cómo
contar cuando llega el misil y estoy
acostumbrado así que esta vez no tenía
miedo asociaciones y voluntarios están
organizando para evacuar a los más
vulnerables que no pueden salir por su
propio pie de zonas como dónetsk y
logan's recorren cientos de kilómetros
en autobuses como este por todo el
frente de batalla voluntarios misioneros
y payasos pasan horas escuchando y
sacando sonrisas a los desplazados
jose casal se viene cada día a ayudar a
este centro de los que no ya cuando lo
sacamos de ahí estamos por la carretera
y se desvía cambiando la cara
bueno hablamos un poco son los más
vulnerables personas con problemas de
movilidad que desde la distancia
aguardan volver a su hogar en el este de
ucrania la tierra donde tienen su vida
hecha